well santa's delivered a lump of coal
early this year with the release of home
sweet home alone sounds like garbage yes
nearly 31 years after the absolute
classic home alone was released the
series has devolved into fart jokes
i'm sorry and whatever the hell this is
so i thought it would be fun to see some
of the main difference that made the
original so endearing and this newer
version well oh this is garbage
i don't know why they're always trying
to remake the classics we'll even go
over some of the differences in the
traps so make sure to like and subscribe
seriously only nine percent of you are
subscribed because here we go
[Music]
while the original starts with that
iconic score and animation the new
version looks like it's been popped into
photoshop by my eight-year-old niece and
right off the bat we're introduced to
pam and jeff mckenzie here they are pam
and jeff mckenzie basically this
version's harry and marv you may be
thinking hey these guys don't look like
hobo criminals well that's one of the
big differences they aren't unlike the
1990 version where harry and marv's
motivations are simple break in and get
money much of the plot of home sweet
home alone is spent building this
complex and contrived justification for
pam and jeff's eventual break-in to max
mercer's home by the way this is max our
home alone kid and i would even argue
he's not even our main character way
more time is spent on following pam and
jeff and trying to make us like them
than max who comes across as a total
brat
you can't promise okay mcdonald's and
not deliver
what a mcshane who steals poor
children's toys at the toy drive
i'm definitely a child need this is his
house now that isn't to say kevin
mcallister isn't a bit of a brat too he
certainly is but there's one key
ingredient or should i say scene that
home sweet home alone misses we have to
empathize and care about the main
character's journey in home alone this
takes place when kevin attacks his
brother for eating his pizza totally
justified which causes complete
pandemonium and everyone in the house
hating him look what you did you little
jerk we care about kevin because which
one of us hasn't been in a situation
where we feel ignored or unloved by our
family this is what makes the ending so
powerful when we see how much kevin and
his family truly love one another the
scene also has the added bonus of
setting up why kevin's dad doesn't have
his son's passport or airplane ticket it
got covered in spilt milk and
accidentally thrown in the trash in home
sweet home alone there is no such scene
you just have a bratty kid who doesn't
like his family but i just don't see why
we have to share our house with every
stupid relative we have one of the
biggest differences between these two
movies is the setup mainly in terms of
how these two kids get left home alone
and why they don't go for help and let
me tell you in the age of cell phones
and the internet home sweet home alone
has to perform some cirque du soleil
level mental gymnastics for us to
believe max could possibly be left home
alone in the original it's pretty simple
a storm has blown out the power the
family is late for their flight to
france and they forget kevin
in the new version we find out that
they're traveling to japan for some
reason and that the day before their
flight the family had to be split up
into two separate flights in the
pandemonium of them leaving in their
ubers they forget max who fell asleep
watching cartoons in the back seat of
their car in the garage and all i'm
thinking about is how short this movie
would be if he got carbon monoxide
poisoning max's uncle thinks that max
must have gotten on that earlier flight
with his mom but that's not the case and
when max finds out he is home alone he
lives it up just like kevin in the
original even dressing up as a woman now
i personally don't have anything against
that who among us hasn't put on our
mom's heels from time to time but bold
move disney i guess the movie can't air
in china anymore
i should also mention that max doesn't
have a cell phone and can't access the
internet through the movie's version of
an alexa because it's programmed in
german he also refuses to go get help
from his neighbors or the police because
he believes that his parents will go to
jail if the police find out they left
him home alone but moving on to the main
catalyst of the story and why i think
pam and jeff are the main characters the
whole story centers around them having
to move out of their home because they
can't pay the bills but when jeff finds
out a creepy antique doll of his mothers
could sell for two hundred thousand
dollars it just might be the financial
christmas miracle they've been looking
for this is where max comes into play
who winds up at the mackenzie's open
house when he really had to use their
washroom there he finds jeff's doll
collection and when the doll goes
missing jeff and pam assume it was max
who took it starting the events of home
sweet home alone where they need to
break into the house and get their doll
back this is what really separates jeff
and pam from harry and mar harry and
marv are just bad people looking to make
a quick buck the film portrays jeff and
pam as this wholesome family down on
their luck unable to buy nice christmas
presents for their children hell they
even volunteer at singing for seniors
the break-in isn't really like harry and
mars it's more to reclaim what was
already theirs so unlike home loan where
you're rooting for kevin to kick the
[ __ ] out of the bad guys with his booby
traps it just kind of feels weird that
max is doing the same thing to these
really nice people who are trying to
save their family the most blatant
crossover between the two films is the
introduction of buzz mcallister kevin's
brother he's all grown up now working
for the police force and kevin is the
owner of mcallister home security which
max's house has buzz really hasn't
changed much no it's been able to obtain
this wild stallion in fact he's only in
two or three scenes he's pretty much the
worst cop around because when he gets a
call that there's a boy home alone he
thinks it's just his brother playing a
prank on him and decides not to look
into it shame on you i also don't know
why the mom and max are british maxwell
johann mercer maybe it was a casting
thing now when max's mom does find out
that they left max home alone there's
only one ticket left to america and she
goes by herself just like katherine
o'hara's character in the original
unfortunately there's no john candy in a
pokeband there's this guy she meets in
the plane but he's totally annoying also
that fake movie kevin watches angels
with filthy souls has gone from film
noir to whatever the hell this sci-fi
monstrosity is and it wouldn't be
christmas without church right in home
alone kevin uses the manger to hide
himself from the burglars and while max
doesn't use the manger like kevin does
it reminds him of his family but it's
the addition of a toy drive which is new
in this version now max like kevin comes
from a very wealthy family yet still
ends up taking a toy from the toy drive
and there's no scene in the church where
max learns not to judge a book by its
cover with the old man it just kinda
ends there there is a choir though so
jeff and pam see max at the church and
decide now is the opportunity to strike
while he's not at home it's perfect
we go now while they're not home and get
our doll back and literally the next
scene they get there and decide to wait
until dark defeating their entire
purpose for leaving we'll wait till it
gets dark and this film is jam-packed
with product placement especially for
kellogg's products like max walks around
with a backpack of fruit loops for some
reason all the time and there are
pop-tarts everywhere i mean the original
did have some with pepsi and frito-lays
but this was pretty distracting speaking
of foods there's a cool easter egg at
pam and jeff's house with little nero's
pizza the same company kevin and his
family order from now we get to what
everyone's come here for the traps
unlike the original the first few traps
that jeff and pam succumb to aren't
created by the kid at all they fall into
an icy pool struggle to get over a stone
wall which jeff then crashes into a
dollhouse thing all of these are just
because they're stupid and not because
of max's ingenuity but then we get to
the booby trap plan kevin has his mapped
out on a piece of paper while max has
written his in chalk on the wall this
was always one of my favorite parts in
the film the creating traps montage and
home sweet home has this too but makes
the tragic mistake of intercutting the
trap making process with these
insufferable singing clips
[Music]
it just takes away from the energy going
into the film's final act now i gotta
say that there were some pretty
ingenious traps in this new version some
of my favorites included a race car
attached to a firecracker which lights
pam's feet on fire the thumbtack nerf
gun or the icicle indiana jones run but
for every cool one there are some
definite misfires like the cookies left
out for santa that jeff eats which were
made of hot sauce the vr machine which
jeff thinks he's actually on a mountain
ledge or stepping on legos which just
don't have the same impact like when
marv stepped on the christmas ornaments
there's also a lot of cgi like this cgi
pack of sugar that's flung at them the
cold breath is cgi and the snow is fake
i'm just a fan of more of the practical
effects like the paint canisters falling
off the second floor in the original
here they've been replaced by flour and
milk and jeff and pam really get put
through some torture but the film
decides to remind us what they're here
for don't you dare judge me
i'm doing this for my family why show us
them getting their [ __ ] knocked out of
them and then remind us that they're
doing this just to save their families
home there are also some memorable lines
that are rehashed for fan service like
this line you guys give up or you're
thirsty for more but in the new version
it feels like it was added in
post-production as an afterthought given
up yet
as jeff and pam finally corner max in
the film's climax we basically learned
the whole thing was just a
misunderstanding max thought they had
come to steal him when all they wanted
was this doll back so he goes from
nearly killing them to staying over at
their place until his mom comes home if
we had known
you were staying here by yourself we
would have handled things a lot
differently
yeah that's the ending well kinda it
turns out that jeff's nephew had the
doll the whole time and for some reason
he decides to chuck it in the middle of
the air almost destroying it but max
ends up catching it and saving the day
[Laughter]
so no one gets arrested like harry and
marv do and jeff and pam learn the moral
of the story because i guess home is
just another word for family right but
stop right there unlike the original we
fast forward one year the mckenzies have
used the money from the sale of the doll
to get their life back on track and now
max and his family seem to have ditched
that whole other family that came to
tokyo with them and are now spending it
with the mercers
obviously this video has no bias in it
at all but i want to hear your thoughts
on which home alone reigns supreme in
the comments below thank you for
watching be sure to like and subscribe
and for more bad takes you can follow me
on twitter and instagram at thingstoryt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much
you